reparations
it's a term you've likely heard before
but what does it mean it's a type of
compensation given to a group of people
who've suffered abuse at the hands of a
more powerful group in the u.s. it's
often talked about in terms of slavery
but slavery was so long ago and some ask
why should black Americans be
compensated now
well proponents argue that the US was
built on the backs of slaves and all our
social institutions continue to
reinforce rigid economic inequalities
against blacks it's easy to see why from
slavery white families got rich bought
land and cemented legacies while black
families were torn apart and kept in
extreme poverty from the dawn of America
the starting line for blacks was far
behind the white majority the
Emancipation Proclamation did little to
end the racial stigma of being black in
America and even less to ensure that X
slaves could access the immense wealth
that white America had accumulated off
their labor while all Americans of all
backgrounds are deemed equal under the
law equality also means equal access to
Economic Opportunity healthcare property
education and justice black people have
been systematically denied these things
for the past 150 years and not just by
Jim Crow laws in the south every major
American social institution has roots in
slavery the u.s. school system is still
unequal and unofficially segregated
teachers and minority schools make less
money and are less likely to be
certified black students are often at a
disadvantage from day one and fewer
black boys graduate from high school
sixty percent of people behind bars in
the u.s. are people of color
and black men are close to six times
more likely than white men to go to
prison
housing discrimination continues as well
thanks to old techniques like red lining
which deny home loans and insurance to
people living in certain areas and
predatory lending blacks have been
forced to live in low-income
neighborhoods and denied the chance to
own homes oh and then there's life
expectance
black men die on average five years
earlier than white men the infant
mortality rate for black babies is more
than twice that of whites socioeconomic
factors like diet lifestyle and lack of
preventative care all come into play
here so you think all of this might make
our nation's leaders want to have a
discussion about reparations but you'd
be wrong Congressman John Conyers jr.
has been introducing the same bill for
25 years calling for a commission to
discuss reparations it's been shot down
every time and while there are many
obstacles in the way of distributing
reparations it's not impossible
take Germany South Africa and Chile all
countries that have given reparations to
groups of people their governments has
treated and even here in the u.s.
reparations have happened in 1988 the
u.s. began the process of reparations
for more than 100,000 surviving
japanese-americans that were placed in
incarceration camps during World War two
reparations don't have to be monetary
they can be commissions for collective
healing investment in underdeveloped
neighborhoods access to skills training
or even major legal reforms there are of
course many questions like who would get
compensated and what specific problems
would be solved reparations don't right
the wrongs of the past nor are they
Amin's by which the conditions of people
who've been grossly abused are somehow
magically fixed but in a country where
the government has yet to formally
apologize for slavery something that
began 400 years ago isn't it time to
start talking about what can be done to
heal those wounds
you